foreign
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
going on right uh my question is my
mother gifted me my sister's car but my
sister wants me to pay a hundred dollars
a month to my mom to pay her what
uh yeah and it's like for 10 grand so
she gifted you a car loan
what is your sister driving yeah
but she's she has her own car like
Alexis I'm just driving her old car so
why are you now obligated to pay your
sister's car loan
that I don't know we we I thought it was
just going to be a gift and just pay a
hundred bucks a month but so what
happened with your sister's car so she
was she paying the payments on this
um that car no that car is fully paid
off she got into an accident with her
previous car got and then Pig got this
car paid off and then they gifted it to
me since she bought a new car and
they're not even using this car
there's no debt on the car and she wants
you to pay there's no debt but it's not
her car anymore it's not her car
yeah so I don't know if I should just
it's under my name too so I don't know
if I should return it sell it and get a
new car and what is the legal obligation
to her at this point
the car's paid off your name's on the
title she has nothing to do with this
car
is she angry because she wasn't gifted
why was your why did your mom give her
your sister's car away to her why didn't
your sister just give you a car
uh
there's a lot going on here
um I guess my mom wanted to put it under
my name so let's say if I get into an
accident they can't sue or go through
the insurance to get into my mother's
house if I were to get sued in that case
again I'm a safe driver but are you on
your own insurance
yes okay if I pay my insurance now so
you're on your own insurance you're not
on your parents insurance
yes and sister's upset because she paid
off the car and then you got it for free
yes that's really where the rub is it's
emotional for her she's like wait wait
how come he just gets it for free and I
had to work to pay that thing off
right does she have a new car loan now
she has a new car with a with a car loan
with a car loan yes so she wants you to
pay to basically pay her car loan off
because it's not fair that you got it
for free
that's what it sounds like yes okay
that's a classic bidder sibling right
there that's classic Behavior well the
truth is you have no obligation to pay
her and I wouldn't and if she wants to
like destroy this relationship over this
that's on her and it's not on you you
had nothing to do with this your mother
gifted this to you out of her own
volition yes
okay right okay yeah and uh is this does
this shock you about your sister is
there like a pattern of like oh yeah
that makes sense or is this like so out
of the blue of like I cannot believe
she's making me do this this is not like
her
it makes sense and it upsets me but I
just have such a good relationship with
my mom it's just my mom's like the
mediator between us like I don't really
have conversations with myself no I'll
give you this Brian this is a 180
therapy ready for this don't triangle
people so your mom needs to get out of
it it's between you and your sister okay
or between your sister and your mom you
y'all don't need to be triangling this
relationship there's a free therapy Dr
John deloney I'm sure it would back me
up on that good stuff Rachel what a
conundrum and a nightmare of a situation
oh my goodness